estamos en puerto resistencia en cali
este es uno de los puntos comunitarios
donde los manifestantes tienen el
control y dónde están realizando
distintas actividades culturales y
sociales la de hoy sábado ha sido cuatro
marchas de distintos puntos de la ciudad
que han concluido aquí en puerto
resistencia unas marchas de madres de
madres indígenas de madres afro y
también de madres del resto de la
sociedad civil que están pidiendo el fin
de la violencia unos llamados al diálogo
que también llegan por parte de los
manifestantes que están estudiando a
hacer pliegos de reivindicaciones para
tratar de desencallar la situación sin
embargo en la noche del viernes fueron
denunciadas unos disparos contra los
manifestantes por parte de furgonetas
blindadas en otro orden de cosas cabe
destacar que en otras partes de la
ciudad también están habiendo
manifestaciones en sectores más
acomodados para pedir el fin de los
bloqueos y el desabastecimiento un
desabastecimiento que las autoridades
locales y nacionales están tratando de
poner fin para que puedan entrar
medicamentos alimentos y combustible